there's so much of the past in today's
lebanon
front lines from the civil war that
ended in 1990 still separate communities
a divide that continues to play out in
the streets and the political arena
now two of the fiercest adversaries are
the main players in the newly elected
parliament
samir jaja the head of the christian
lebanese forces who has been the most
vocal critic of hezbollah accusing its
military wing of undermining the
lebanese state and implementing iran's
agenda
we are not ready to compromise with our
political platform we will coordinate
with the pro-reformers and others in the
opposition to chart the way forward
hezbollah which says its weapons are to
defend lebanon from israel and other
threats was stripped of its majority in
parliament its leader nasrallah
acknowledging that
the priority should be issues affecting
people's lives and this can't be done
without cooperation and partnership
because the alternative is chaos
but negotiating a deal on the makeup of
the next government won't be easy
hezbollah has made clear it won't accept
demands by the opposition for a cabinet
of experts to rescue the collapsed
economy
it insists on political representation
hezbollah has many enemies chief among
them samir jaja who nasrella has
repeatedly accused of wanting to start a
civil war but in his first post-election
speech nasrallah called for calm and
called on his supporters not to chant
sectarian slogans and not to provoke
others who have different political
views
not too long ago blood was spilled onto
the streets
for hours hezbollah allied fighters and
supporters of the lebanese forces turned
part of beirut into a battleground
we have to put our hands together as
lebanese because as the results of the
elections show no one can eliminate the
other
hezbollah's weapons dominated political
campaigns before the vote which the
group called its most important
political battle it may have lost this
round but it is still the main power
broker here senator al jazeera beirut